newt gingrich is here newt is a
remarkable figure
he was the most consequential republican
speaker of the last century
so he knows all the smoke-filled room
stuff how to get your legislation
through how to flip a swing district
all the micro politics of the 24 7
hamster wheel but he also has a very
far-sighted grasp
of the big picture which is what we want
to uh talk to
nude about today it's great to see me
just go with this where you want
is it too late to do anything about
china supplanting america and if so
what are the consequences for all of us
well i think you basically were right
in warning that if we don't change
direction then china will probably
be the dominant country in the world and
that has really bad
implications for all of us because
nobody who has ever experienced a
chinese totalitarian system
has any great desire to see that applied
united states
it's a terrible system it tortures
people
it locks people up it totally censors
them
it's a tremendously efficient machine of
tyranny
uh i i'm an optimist
i think that we've been challenged
before and now
we've come back with enormous success i
think uh
in fact i'm writing a book called beyond
biden where i'm looking beyond the
current disaster
because i i actually think this will be
a very educational
uh four-year period uh and i think
people will come out of it
uh dramatically more conservative and
more ready to take on the chinese
one of the examples is we have got to
break the power of the teachers union to
continue destroying children
the greatest ally the chinese have are
the teachers unions
because they're guaranteeing that
american young people
aren't learning enough to compete with
the chinese
in technology and science in management
this is a real crisis for us much bigger
than a military crisis
but we also have to recognize just one
last thing which is
if you watch what the chinese communists
have been doing around taiwan
if you watch what they've done in the
last two months around the philippines
this is a dictatorship that is testing
the biden administration
uh just as putin is testing him in
ukraine
and in both places they're finding
weakness
confusion and an invitation to a
disaster
yeah we we think we're being tested in
the pacific but you can also say as much
about the indian ocean where they've
built basically a string of ports uh
done
99-year leases with sri lanka they're
they're they're basically uh annexing
certain critical
chunks of the globe uh you were quite
right to say that education is possibly
our
greatest structural defect the advantage
that chinese have is that they don't
waste their time
on the stuff that we they don't waste
two months
talking about whether you should take
down confederate statues
uh and this kind of thing in other words
then that's a huge advantage
if you can just dispense with all that
rubbish isn't it
well it is but also just think about our
schools
we now have schools that teach the
oregon department of education put out a
publication saying
you shouldn't try to find a single
answer in mathematics
because that's an example of white
supremacy i mean this is insane
this is literally insane we have a
proposal
in california that school children
should
basically chant to three aztec gods
one of whom was the central figure for
human sacrifice
i mean the chinese aren't engaged in
this kind of uh
woke there are the best of my knowledge
there's no woke division
of the chinese society and so they don't
have to put up with the nonsense
that we have to pretend is serious